[Music]
hello YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
48th episode of dirty chess tricks in
this episode you are going to see a
wonderful trick and a high profile trap
in the Kings Indian attack from the
white perspective now interesting part
is critical tricky position can be
reached with two different opening model
as you can see I have highlighted here
however in this video I have choose the
most popular choice namely Evo this
trick can be effectively used in two now
in practice against both French as well
as a success iliyan and it is such
invisible that so far three Grand
Master's and few title players have
fallen into it we are now going to
follow a game where a GM has been
crushed by this beautiful trick here
black start with the French defense a
six and white responds with the typical
kie setup starting with d3 okay defy on
the board attacking on e4 and white
calmly defenders with night to day two
so as you can see I have highlighted by
the arrows this opening is all about
structure rather than proper model so
what white wants to do is he wants to
play Knight G to F 3 followed by G 3 and
Bishop to G 2 and then castle on the
Kings side after that what will put his
rook on even and as you can see if black
prematurely castle on the King side then
white get a typical King side attack
which is always a fun to play as a white
okay so let's see how Grandmaster
respond to this opening well some of the
moves are very Mitchell typical French
defense move Knight to f6 and after the
move Knight to f3 black obviously gain
the space on the Queen side with c5 okay
no issues it doesn't bother white to go
with his typical Kings Indian attack
setup starting with g3 and after Knight
to c6 Bishop to g2 as you can see black
doesn't want to play Bishop to d6 as it
is not looking at the right direction so
the correct move is Bishop to e7
planning to castle on the Kings side at
the right moment
well white plan is very obvious he wants
to castle now
and if black castle at this point then
as I have mentioned earlier
what has this team attic in the picture
which is very difficult to handle for
the black camp so accordingly what most
of the good black player does is they do
not commit Castle instantly and rather
develop his rest of the army first and
then at the right moment they Castle so
if you carefully look at black cam the
only piece which hasn't developed is
that poor bishop on c8 and accordingly
the best choice here for the black is to
continue with b6 and activate that light
square bishop okay rook to even Square
vacation for the night and black plays
the obvious move Bishop to b7 here
why choose the move c3 to restrict the
knight movement and accordingly black
respond with Queen to c7 remain flexible
stopping any fire advance and at the
right moment black and even castle on
the Queen side well guess what we have
reached to the critical position and
before I move on I like you too
this video and find out what mu you are
going to play with sets of a nasty trick
well I hope you do find out this amazing
resource if I hahaha what a mu
well you may say hang on
doesn't white blunder upon because after
the simple move Knight F to d7 black is
attacking three times on e5 and funny
enough there is no easy way to defend
the e5 pawn why let's see well first
obvious an initial move d4 instantly
failed due to the simple tactic C
captures d4c captures d4 and now this
typical Queen side night John Knight to
before and as you can see a night to see
two E's on the card which is not easy to
parry and if white supposed to play
moves like rook to have fun getting out
of the fork then he get this ultimate
shock Bishop to e6 and I think game is
over
right there well you may say what about
Queen - E - doesn't it look so natural
defending the e5 square from all aspect
it looks so good but black has this
amazing attacking resource g5 and you
can see White is in a big danger as g4
is coming up and as the knight will move
away the e5 pawn will draw and most
likely black is going to cast on the
Queen side which give him a very
comfortable and in fact attacking
position so the big question arise if
none of these two moves are working then
how the hell on earth what is going to
defend efile
well that's where our tricky
continuation comes into the picture and
believe it or not white here has this
super Camus night to have fun which sets
up a very huge cunning trap first sight
this looks completely stupid right
because you are not defending on ePHI
and if black wish he can easily take on
ePHI square that's the case in the
database as there are more than hundred
games played from this position where
I'm afraid many white players doesn't
know about this trap in detail so pay
special attention guys my big question
is what happens if black just capture on
ePHI kindly pause the video take your
time and find out what white is up to
after this more okay are you ready
well before we look at this there is one
point I like to mention that instead of
capturing this spawn if black plays
other moves let's say castle on the
kingside then the simplest move is now
d4 walks because the same thing C
captures d4c captures d4 and night to be
four doesn't walk this time as White has
this saving resource Knight to b3 and in
fact this position is quite better for
the white as it has a space in the
center of the board and soon we are
going to kick this Knight and get a
slightly advantageous position that's ok
but what to do after black capture on e5
well here it doesn't matter whether
black captured with the sea Knight or
the denied we are going to capture this
Knight and black has nothing better to
capture with another night
afterwards white reveal this nasty idea
Bishop to f4 pinning down the knight and
threatening d4
so in case of Bishop to f6 or the Moab
six
we are definitely go ahead and play the
move d4 and nab the piece but I guess
once again you will say hang on I'm not
a fool I will play the move Bishop to d6
not only unpinning denied but at this
point I'm a clear pond up and now d4
does involve because it doesn't lose a
piece right so what is the big point
behind sacrificing the Ipoh once again
guys the ball is in your court
kindly pause the video and find out
nasty continuation from here onwards
which gives wide a completely winning
position I hope you find this decisive
sequence namely Bishop captures if I
Fisher captures ePHI and here comes the
most important move of the game what a
move well the first thing this Queen has
done is it's a checking on e5 Bishop but
the most important part is it has pinned
down the f7 pawn so that means black can
no longer support the e5 Bishop and once
the bishop moves the most popular choice
here is Bishop to f6 afterwards now you
see it right yup
rook captures c6 boom getting our pawn
back and not only that if that's the
case then I'm not going to record this
video but after anymore let's say King
to d8 or King to a fade
white has a completely winning
continuation if you operon plays King to
d8 then I have attached a sample line in
the PG in where more or less white
continue with the same exchange
sacrifice which happens after King to a
phage and rook captures AB 6 the winning
blow it's very funny right because if
you compare this position just before 4
to 5 moves black has a rock-solid
position and now his King looks very
shaky and on top white has a tremendous
attacker just see how easily white crust
a high rated GM after falling sequence
Queen to at 6 Jack attacking on f6 so
black initially defend with King to e7
now instead of king to e7 if black has
gone on g8 then night to e3 is a very
strong reply this night is going to
reroute to their Phi Square where it
will be very hard for black to defend
his position ok
King to e7 the most natural move comes
into the picture
yup rook to even check King to d7 and
now Queen captures up 6 so that is very
simple we want to play rook to e7 and
nab the Queen something black has to pay
attention immediately so he continued
with Queen to d6
attacking on the Queen and naturally
enough white nabbed f7 pawn and check
the black King King goes to the d8 or c6
more or less it has to face the same
reply which he faced after the moon King
to c8 as white continue with this
thematic check the shock to s3 King to
be said for side it looks like black has
safeguard his King
but not a just an illusion as after rook
to e6 black is in a completely hopeless
position if Queen moves anywhere as I
have highlighted by the arrows then rook
to e7 is a very strong reply and in the
game black plays the move Queen to f8
hoping that if white exchange the Queen
then somehow black can survive this
position but as happen in many case just
one end black resigns last time guys
pause the video and find out that nuke
which finish off black camp okay then
the decisive blue happens with yup rook
to e8 boom after this black simply
resigned but if some of you don't
understand why black resigns well what
happens if black simply take this rook
well it's a big time deflection moon has
after Queen to f4 check you can see
those juicy diagonals which literally
sniping the black ink only more Queen to
e5 and after Queen captures e5 it's a
big time checkmate for the black ink
what a wonderful game and a victory by a
white camp that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this informative video
on the King's in an attack Kraken trick
remember play the movie if I give you up
on and hope to capture the ePHI pond
with this thematic move Knight to have
fun and once black capture the pawn then
he's not going to forget the treatment
which you are going to deliver him well
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment on my
video and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care